One fire just sent me. This works worst VMA accepted speech of all time.
He says.
Nirvana, the nominees for best new artists.
Oh, I mean, I don't know who that girl is,
but she couldn't look like somebody more in 1992. She's got leopard print,
like mini skirt on or mini dress on.
And she's got the red hair with the puff out.
And then boys to men is next to her in a varsity jacket.
Talk about them, them data.
Talk about Baya yacht up Dodd up route. Oh wow. Wow.
Anyway.
A pretty eclectic robot. They range from Seattle rock and roll sound.
Dean didn't realize. Wow. I didn't realize boys man was 14 when they did this.
When they blasted on the scene, this kid looks 12
[inaudible] man, man, man, where's my mommy.
To the fusion of wrap soul and RNB.
So Midwestern. Didn't give a.
Do the fusion of rap soul and RNB.
Hates rap. You can tell that the fusion of rap Sol in RMB.
To an alternative rock band. Oh dude.
It was so 1992 to be the guy
in the R and B group with the circular glasses low on your nose.
Like you were an old Butler. Yes.
Like you were going to be like, would you like that?
Would you like your chicken ConEd or warmed up today.
To the evocative music of a new folk singer?
Oh, here comes the guy with the low voice. This guy he's good. By the way,
he got the lowest voice in boys to men.
And let's see what it sounds like in real life. He's probably just like, yeah.
So anyway, y'all here's Nirvana. Here are the nominees eight,
the microphone eight. The microphone is alone
guys in the break room just went like, Oh,
and took the microphones off hurt so bad. It's like, look, look, I mean, dude,
come on, dude. Learn how to use the microwave, your R and B singer for sake.
Look at these girls. Okay.
They range from Seattle rock and roll sound to the fusion of Brown
soul and R and B to an alternative rock band,
old white Butler to the evocative music of a new folks
here to nominees.
Dude,
[inaudible] all have varsity jackets on at an award show
set. That's respectful. Love it.
[Inaudible].
The song of all time. The loneliest song of all time. That was, Hey,
shut up butters. You're an incell. Listen.
Tennessee. This song
for teenage girl needs. Now.
I guess if these guys are singing in a field or not,
if you're listening to the podcast, so it.
[Inaudible].
No, no.
What the world needs now is not another folk singer and it never needs that.
For smells like teen spirit
winner takes all great. There we go.
And before we announced the winner,
I like to plug the Christmas album that was previously recorded by boys to man.
And what's villains. Now I would say the winner.
Oh man. So uncomfortable. They're all laughing. And there's so Maddy to that.
They're like, whatever you do, don't plug the pictures of them. Please.
Here we go. I'd never seen this by the way.
I like to thank my family and our record label
and our true fans.
You can't believe everything you've seen here now, Kenya.
Oh my God, that guy.
That guy who came in was that Dave Grohl now. Right? When that, Oh,
that gets even great. That it's not, they were okay. When that guy came in,
he was like, Oh, I'm going to shut this down, dude. He was like, here we go.
I'm going to shut the down. He was thinking of it on the way to the show.
It was like, if we win,
which we probably will because there's a lot of heat around us.
I'm going to dip in and I'm going to say that thing when Kurt Cobain is doing
the thing and he thought it was going to shut the down,
he thought everyone was going to lose their minds.
He thought Wilson Phillips was gonna start crying.
And that Boisman was just going to start that that's it [inaudible].
Wrap around. Wow.
Wow. Begans is going to lead us to dream about this every day.
That guy, Oh, it's really hard to, Oh,
this is where it, that's where it went off the rails.
You can tell I've never seen this,
but right there with like a depression is when it went off the rail. Here we go.
You can't believe everything you've seen here now, can you.
Basic blanket the system thing. You know,
he's wearing purple pants now, now,
now how mad is Kurt Cobain that he did it, but he was like,
I'm just going to roll with it this year. It doesn't matter. Anyway.
You know, it's really hard to believe everything you read.
Oh, Oh, remember Joseph Goebbels.
Oh
wow. Wow.
It's so funny. Their music like means so much to so many people and like,
they've been there. Like, they're just like
what that Ray may pick when people are like, feel that, you know,
just getting raped by the system. Like just so good. And then,
Oh no, no, no. And just 15 year old kids were just like,
God it speaks to me. I love this music. And then.
And our true fans. And then dude,
this dude just when it comes to talk and this is why this guy's the drummer or
whatever, you can't believe everything you've seen.
Oh bro, pick up an instrument. And then, and then this,
and then you're so mad because what's his name? Kurt Cobain was like,
I'm going to, I'm going to kill it. I'm going to do the thing. And that like,
I couldn't wait. He thought cocoa bean, wasn't going to do it. He was like,
he's pitching out. He's not going to do it.
So he dipped in and the cocoa is like,
I got to go in early and I got to do this now. And then just completely.
You know, it's really hard to believe everything you read.
Remember Joseph Goebbels. Y Oh.
He's a BI. So wait. So it's really, you know, it's really hard to
believe everything you read. I think he meant to say
don't believe everything you read. It's it's really hard to
believe everything you read. Okay.
He's like the guy from South park. Who was that guy?
Chris crisp Crist,
sir. Danish. Chris Novo select
Novoselic eh,
Chris Anthony Novoselic Croatian. Oh, that's one thing.
Croatians are the strongest people in the world.
One time I wrestled a Croatian guy.
I was like rustling a tree after Nevana disbanded, fallen from Kurt,
Kurt Cobain as a drift. Apart from a musical endeavors.
Nova cellar has been active politically. Oh really? That's odd.
He's been active politically ever since that moment, including a creature. Wow.
That's hilarious. Well,
that is what let's see the comments.
This is the most nineties thing I've ever seen. Yeah. Really?
Remember when MTV look, kids.
That's what happens when punk rock gets big?
Wait, who's Joseph Goebbels. I've heard it of that.
Oh my God.
I mean saw Hitler's propaganda guy. Eh?
Not the time.
Well you won. Hey dude. You're the best band on earth. Amen.
Remember Hitler set.
Not the time. Don't care. How punk rock Yar.
12 year olds are watching mom. Who's Joseph Goldberg. Oh, he hated Jews.
What's that? Uh, there's racism in the world. What? You like?
Some people don't like Jews and,
but with all my black people that some people don't like, Oh,
really shouldn't know it already.
Wow. Dude.
Look at this guy. Just making up comment.
They didn't like what was being said on the teleprompter.
That's why you can see Kurt reading and just saying thanks.
Chris was just saying they are propagandists. All right, man.
You know you're 50.
Oh man. Wow, man.